because i have my own show i have a
responsibility to say things that people
need to know
but that aren't being said it's a cool
opportunity that i don't take lightly
there are very big obvious truths no one
wants to say on tv but
i will so i can't believe i have to say
this but
you matter even though there are
protests
against having you around or making sure
you're cared for or have
rights you matter even though some
people are going to hate your guts just
for fun
and i'm sorry it doesn't change the fact
that you matter
and another thing i can't believe i have
to say this but
oh women in new york city stop cutting
in line and being like
what me i didn't know i know you know
you've been on this earth a thousand
years but you don't know what a line is
please you're lucky i have my own show
or i will
whup your ass and i can't believe i have
to say this
but it is wrong for the president
to incite violence against you his
racist
comments not only make people feel
empowered to physically harm minorities
but make them feel like it's a patriotic
thing to do
that is wrong and you deserve better
also i can't believe i have to say this
but
stop getting mad about spoilers if you
don't want me to spoil something for you
watch it it's a pandemic i know you have
time
i have two drugs and i have time and
this goes
double for things that have been out for
a while there's no such thing as a harry
potter spoiler
it came out 19 years ago although
spoiler the lady who wrote it is
transphobic
and while i'm saying things i can't
believe i have to say
i'd be remiss if i didn't say this
what happened to brianna taylor was the
product of a system
made to protect the oppressor and it's
okay
if that verdict knocked the air out of
you
it is fair to look at it like cops can
just murder me with no repercussions and
that makes me sad
that's fair but i also choose to look at
the fact that
this injustice organized millions of
americans who
previously were sitting on the sidelines
but it should have never happened
and it acts as a terrible reminder of
the reality
of the value of a black woman in america
so there you go spoilers don't exist
anymore
you deserve to feel safe in your own
country oh lady
and most of all and i can't stress this
enough you matter
i can't believe i had to say all that
all right everybody
sometimes it's tough to say what needs
to be said
all right but we did it we should feel
proud it can also be tough to hear it
now watching a show about current events
can be real anxiety inducing
and there's nothing we want less than
for you to leave our show feeling all
riled up
so allow me to fill your mind with
beautiful thoughts so that you can truly
relax
this is something i i should have done a
minute ago but i didn't i just did it
now
sorry i got caught up in the [ __ ] i was
saying before it's a little deep
but now we're on to this all right and
this is
the cool down
relax breathe think
happy thoughts about beautiful
roses a sneezing puppy
a perfectly cooked lasagna
a gentle summer breeze
headphones coming out of your pocket
perfectly
untangled a huge
sail on those pants you like
a hot person smiling at you on the
sidewalk
an ice cream truck but the horn
is your mother saying she's proud of you
14 cash
a tiny man playing a large tuba
a dog barking at a white guy
a teenager saying she's actually
pretty cool and they're talking about
you
the bartender saying it's on the house
one of those viral photos of a white
baby
hugging a black baby a sincere
apology from your college boyfriend
a candle that smells like angela bassett
a shirt that feels like a hug from
angela bassett
a man with 20 20 vision confusing you
with academy award nominee angela
bassett i hope you enjoyed that footage
of my parents
that was cool
[Music]
you